thanks for coming to the last day of the
summer school and workshop uh one thing
to note there's been a change to the
schedule so we'll only have two
tutorials today in the morning session
and then we will break for lunch and
that will be the conclusion
of the week so so we end about 12 30
today
okay so the first tutorial will be
uh by easton dyer who's at google
research he's done a lot of interesting
work on
scaling models and understanding models
behavior as they scale
both theoretically and empirically and i
think will tell us a bit about both
directions
thanks ethan thanks a lot um yeah thanks
for the opportunity to speak um
and let me say if if anyone wants to
interrupt at any point with any kind of
question that's great so please don't
hesitate
um
yeah so today i'm going to be talking
about work sort of all orbiting the
question of um when is scale uh enough
to solve some particular problem of
interest and here i'll be talking about
model
compute and data set scale
um
so uh
right so i'm sure
many are familiar with the fact that
model performance has just been uh
systematically improving with scale um
here are some you know now out of date
uh scaling plots um on large language
models so the left is uh performance
versus compute for gpt family models
and the right is similar for
lambda models which is a google
decoder only language model
and you know not only is performance
improving on cross-entropy which is
maybe nebulous but if we go and look at
downstream tasks we care about uh these
also often
show
systematic improvement so
here's a plot
aggregating the tasks evaluated in the
gpt-3 if you shot paper
and we also see that that improvement
there is um
you know is marching along um and you
know if if we could maybe scale up a few
more orders of magnitude at least on
these tasks uh we would we would hit
broadly human level performance
um
so right so the the questions um that
i'd like to focus on are sort of how can
we understand the systematic improvement
and and what tasks uh are solved in this
way just by skill alone and what tasks
are not
so um here's an outline of what i'm
hoping to talk about so um first i'm
going to talk about uh using linear
models or kernel methods as a nice toy
arena to understand um scaling um
and then i'll talk about empirical work
first i'll talk about big bench which is
um a large language model benchmark
that's aimed at probing this question of
of what kinds of tasks uh
are are susceptible to scaling um and
then i'll focus on a few different areas
first i'll focus on
uh how catastrophic forgetting scales uh
and then i'll talk about some more
trying to use scaling to um to solve
quantitative reasoning problems
okay
so
um
right so uh before jumping into
empirical studies um
i want to review scaling in linear
models um
this is nice it's an analog analytically
tractable system uh that exhibits a lot
of the qualitative phenomena we see in
deep networks um
in some cases the analogy can be made
precise you know for instance if we're
talking about uh very wide networks or
if we're talking about fine tuning then
maybe what we're talking about is
literally a linear model but even aside
from that
it can be a useful laboratory to build
uh intuition about scaling laws
um
and so the setup uh that uh that i'll
try to walk us through is a teacher
student setup where we have some teacher
network capital f uh and it's built out
of some large uh usual you know you can
think infinite if you want number of
features capital fm um and then we have
a student network little f uh which is
built out of some student features uh
little fmu
and those can just be a random subset of
the teacher features um and uh here
uh let's see can i point to things um
so here uh the the the subsetting is
just being denoted by this projection
matrix script script p
and uh
we'll draw the teacher weights um just
gaussian uh
mean zero and then train uh train the
student just with an msu loss
sorry so what is little f mu so little f
mu is just some subset of these big some
random subset of these big
fm features so you have some features
for your teacher you just you know you
have 100 features you pick 10 of them
randomly and those are your student
features
okay so um this is uh you know this is a
quadratic problem we can exactly find
the uh find the optimum um
and uh in the um
uh in
the uh data rich setting so many more
training data points than student
features it's convenient to write the
loss in terms of uh this kernel which is
um
just the uh feature by feature kernel
the the you know features evaluated and
averaged over over the um
uh data distribution so this is a
population future feature kernel um and
in the in the large data limit the the
loss takes this form
uh where with this p is the projector
from before um and we can ask um
uh
you know how does this get corrected if
we're not strictly in the infinite
training data set size limit but in the
large large but finite data set size
limit and in that case um you know again
in this whole regime we can solve this
exactly and what we find is that we can
write this not just in terms of this
population kernel but instead we have an
empirical kernel like plane c
which is just um
the empirical average over our training
data set size
and this empirical kernel concentrates
around the population kernel um
and and it has uh it has higher moments
suppressed by powers of one over data
set size um and so if we if we um
ask well how does the you know how does
the large you know p still less than d
so d is still much larger than the
number of
student features but not necessarily
infinite you know loss scale we get
something which looks like this we have
the infinite data loss piece lfp plus a
one over data set size correction
uh and the point to emphasize here is
just that if we think about how this is
scaling with data set size it's um
it's a you know fixed exponent in
particular it doesn't depend on
particulars of my data distribution
um okay so we can also ask though in
this limit how do we scale um when p is
large so here p is still much less than
d but both are large and what does the
scaling look like at large number of
student features
um and for this we actually do need to
know something about this kernel that
goes in here
okay so we need to put in some onsites
that is representative of the data that
we'd like to understand the scaling for
and and so how how do we do that um well
we can start by just empirically looking
at what kernels look like in trying to
understand what would be a good onsats
for properties of uh kernel on realistic
data
and so here i'm plotting in this case
both random feature kernels but for two
different setups so the left is what the
kernel looks like if i take uh uniform
random data on a sphere
uh and the right is what a kernel looks
like if i take random the same random
features but now on mnist digits or take
mnist and pool it at different scales
okay and so on the left we see something
where uh we have highly degenerate
eigenvalues and the degeneracy just
grows and grows as we move out in in the
spectrum and there's this is easy to
understand this is coming from the fact
that that's set up this data is highly
symmetric so if it's uniform on the
sphere this has rotational symmetry and
that rotational symmetry is what's
giving this degeneracy and the
eigenvalues
and that looks qualitatively quite
different from what pooled mnist or
most real data sets that one evaluates
kernels on look like and those look more
like a long power law type behavior in
the eigenvalues
um
uh
yeah so um
is there some understanding of why
pooling at uh at
different sizes makes that why does it
make the spectral decay faster
um
uh
uh
yes um there is some intuition um
so one which i'll talk about in a second
one
well let me maybe i'll talk about this
so so
uh if you're thinking that this scaling
comes from some property of smooth
functions on a d-dimensional manifold
then larger exponent is corresponds to a
smaller dimensional manifold and so if
you think that like you're decreasing
the data dimension this way
i guess it's not it's not um
yeah it like it so if you think pooling
is like sort of removing information and
then maybe can be compressed to a
smaller dimensional manifold that might
give you some intuition although you
might actually think the data manifold
should be the same and compression
should be harder so
anyways i think i could i don't have a
like perfect argument but
okay so
so this um
right so this kind of uh behavior
motivates an on top like this where the
eigenvalues of the kernel follow this
power law behavior um where the the
either value is going like i to the
one over i to the alpha k plus one
uh
okay
so
um if we make this assumption uh then we
can actually um
solve
for the scaling of the loss the test
loss with respect to the number of
student
student
features exactly
and that can be done either using
diagrammatic methods or replica trick
but there's actually a pretty easy way
to um to estimate the scaling if if
alpha k is large and it actually gives
the same scaling as the exact uh is the
exact computation and so the the way to
think about that is um you know here i
have some exact uh kernel uh script c
and here i have some projection of this
kernel onto the student student number
of features um and if the uh if the top
eigen directions align between these two
things then there's a cancellation
between this and this so you know for
instance if p was the identity if i had
all the features these two would just
exactly cancel and i'd get no loss so
the whole loss is coming from the fact
that we're subsetting this kernel down
to the student student features um and
if if the way this works is that the top
eigen directions align then those
eigenvalues cancel and so
uh if alpha k is large then then all of
the eigenvectors of this projected
kernel will
will approximately align with those of
the true kernel and then we just get
only the remaining directions of the
true kernel that we have to sum up and
so we get a sum of these uh eigenvalues
up from uh you know the number of
features beyond the student up to would
be s if we have s futures or taking that
to infinity up to infinity
um and so that gives us this scaling
which is the number of student features
um uh to the minus alpha k
um and in particular um
this uh this exponent depends on the uh
assumption that we made about the data
in this mild way and that we saw
different data can lead to different
power and so this scaling depends on the
data through that through that power
um so we can rerun this whole story
instead of being in the data rich limit
we can be in the large model over
parametrized limit
um and and so d is much less than p and
in that case it's it's more convenient
to write things in terms of this dual
data data kernel um which is built um
built out of the same features but now
we're averaging over feature space and
looking at the kernel on data points
and here k bar
is uh you know just like we projected
the kernel onto student features here
now we're projecting the data data
kernel onto the training data set
um and again we find that that um
we have uh an expansion where the the
full loss in terms of um
number of student features and training
data set size um
uh has this
universal term which scales like one
over the number of student features and
a
and a
data dependent data set size scaling
um
so
just like summarizing this in a simple
picture if we assume some power law
scaling for our kernel spectrum then
that gives rise uh in these different
limits to a power law scaling with um
with data set size for over parametrized
models and a power law scaling with
model size for under parameterized
models and and with the same exponent
related to this fundamental scaling of
the kernel
um
but you can ask like you know can i get
some intuition for where that power law
of the kernel is coming from you know
you just like looked at some data i said
it looks like this and this is sort of
yeah what i was getting to is um there's
a few different ways you can get some
intuition but one way
comes from thinking about uh you know
properties of kernels on smooth
manifolds and there's classic work going
back to vial um
that if i have a smooth kernel
uh with some smoothness condition for
instance say it's in it's in ct um then
i know that my eigenvalues have to be
bounded and they have to be bounded to
fall off uh at least like one
over i to the one plus t over d um and
so t is this parameter controlling my
smoothness and d is the dimension of the
manifold i'm in so larger larger
exponents um you know as i vary data if
i want to view that as changing the data
manifold that corresponds to smaller uh
smaller dimensions
um
and okay i mean this bound was true also
for that degenerate spectrum that i
showed at the beginning but the the
extra assumption um
is that oh and yeah so this goes back uh
goes back to
to vial the extra assumption is that uh
if we don't have any symmetries if we
just have generic smooth functions on
this manifold then what we'll get is
something that saturates the bound
whereas these degenerate things
subsaturay
um right and so that then you have a
picture here that some you know
some uh smooth generic
kernels on on on d-dimensional manifolds
give rise to the spectral scaling of the
kernel and then give rise to the lost
scaling in these different limits
um
right so um
so this this is uh you know uh
another way of summarizing this picture
so here are um
experiments from random feature models
on mnist um and we have these four
different regimes so
uh
we call um the uh scaling with respect
to data set size in the large data data
rich uh regime um that's that's here and
the scaling with respect to parameter
count um
in the over parametrized regime that's
here so i like to refer to these as
variance limited because that scaling
just comes from
calculating the variance of how the
kernel concentrates um around its its
infinite d or infinite infinite p limit
and there we get these data independent
exponents close to one um and then we
have these other regimes so like the
data set size scaling for over
parameterized models or the model set
size scaling uh for for data rich models
where we get this uh data dependent data
dependent scaling um
okay so so that's great you know fine
here's some property of linear models
you can ask well is this borne out when
we look at more more uh realistic models
on more interesting data sets and so
this is some experiments on on
uh deep models um
uh wide resnet uh and and some deep mlps
a few other models um
that um that have qualitatively similar
behavior so here we get these variants
limited data independent exponents and
here we get these um data dependent uh
non-trivial exponents
and just mapping this onto something
that that maybe is is more familiar if
we look at these these two panels in
both cases we're varying the number of
parameters in our network um and so if
you're if you like thinking about double
descent um we can ask okay we're used to
like making plots where we look at loss
varying number of parameters that's
that's what we're doing here how does
this map on onto this double descent
picture that i know and love
um or or you know maybe feel mixed about
um
yeah so
so the this this resolution limited uh
corresponds to the approach to the
descent so we're taking we're you know
we're scaling such that we're pushing
this point way to the right and then
we're really focusing on the power law
decay to the double decent fee
um whereas uh whereas this uh variance
limited over parameterized scaling
that's about you know how do i fall back
down to the floor when i'm when i'm in a
in an over parametrized model
um
and um
maybe one one thing to note is that
you know if your currency is compute and
you want to get the best model for uh
the lease compute and you're able to
change your training data set size or
your number of parameters um then you
know the scaling that is you know
more relevant in that scenario is
typically this resolution limited
because
once i'm over parametrized you know
i get some performance gains perhaps by
making my model bigger but actually if i
just collected more data that would be a
uh
and train on that data that would that
would lead to larger performance gains
you know given the amount of compute so
you know often we're thinking about you
know
cfar some some setup where the training
data set size is like you know
uh
is just handed to us and we can't change
it and that way okay fine we can get
better performance by scaling up but if
you're allowed to
tune either knob it's typically this
this resolution limited regime which
corresponds to the the compute efficient
way to improve models
okay so so just to conclude um
uh what you know so these linear models
can exhibit these four regimes of
scaling that we see um and it requires
building in uh assumptions about the
structure of data uh for that to emerge
um
and i think you know this can be
extended to a lot of other analyses that
are that are interesting and also
relevant for for you know deep models uh
you know studying scaling with effective
compute uh or time and and can relate to
this you know this deep double descent
story um
and um the main thing i want to take
away though is just the message that
like uh which maybe okay maybe i'm
preaching to the choir um or maybe not
but the linear models i think can still
be quite a useful you know nice solvable
setup where we can build a lot of
intuition that carries over to um to you
know
realistic models we care about
um
well
um okay uh
does anyone anyone have any questions
before i move on
yeah i may have missed this connection
but was there a relationship between the
rate and decay of the kernel spectra and
then the rate of decay of the loss yes
yeah yeah so um
they are it's a different different by
one
so um
so
uh
yeah so here
um we this is our kernel spectrum
uh which is giving us this rate of decay
of one plus alpha k and then just doing
the sum gives us the scaling with
respect to it
thank you um so you said that if we had
the choice between increasing the number
of data or increasing the size of the
model it's better to concern about it
but it's not trivial from your current
analysis right i mean
do those theoretical analysis show that
at some point so one um yeah one way to
see that from this um
is
uh it
it takes it so so yeah so um you know
we're comparing let's just so it's not
complete i haven't told you what this
factor is but let's just assume it's
like some order one number and we can
actually compute it
so so this decays really quickly
right it's an exponent of one whereas
these alpha k's because because they're
like in this case coming from t over d
or just empirically they're often quite
small
um and so you you quickly
uh
exhaust all the benefits you're getting
from this
and then at that point
because you're already in a p much
greater than d limit and so then at that
point you know like because this has
fallen so quickly then gains come from
just increasing
okay great yeah thanks thanks for the
questions
the corresponding uh
rate of scaling in the
in the um data limited regime
it's
what determines the corresponding
exponent in the regime where you have
like lots and lots of parameters but let
me do that uh so
um are you asking what is the data set
or model size scaling
the dataset scaling in the limited data
yeah yeah so that is this kernel so like
the limited thing
in the limited regime is always set by
the kernel spectrum and the abundant
thing scaling is set by
just being one so like in the data
limited regime your data set scaling is
this alpha k
and your model set scaling because
that's the over parametrized regime is
just one over p
and it flips in on the other side but do
we need to look at like the eigen
coefficients of the
target function
so so uh in this setup um
there is
you know because the target is built by
this t-shirt
it's all controlled by the kernel you
can say well what does that have to do
with uh real data that has a target that
i'm trying to learn about and it seems
to be that um
at least uh
in some analyses
the the it's really about this data
manifold that determines the scaling
independent of turret so for instance
you can run an experiment where you
train on c400
okay but instead of taking the 100 uh
classes you can superclass them so you
could do you know artificial versus
natural that's a two-class
categorization of c400 where you could
do 50 classes or 20 classes you can dial
this and you can ask does that change my
scaling exponent and it doesn't seem to
change the scaling exponent so i don't
have a great uh i mean i think this is
again something you could probably try
to understand in linear models and i i
think that would be interesting to work
through but it seems like empirically
that the changing the input data has
more effect on this exponent than
keeping the input data the same and
changing uh properties of the labels
okay yeah so um
so now i'm gonna shift gears and and
discuss um some empirical work
uh focused on yeah trying to understand
um what tasks are solved solved by scale
um and and when we need new ideas um
and so one one effort in this direction
is this big bench project um
and so the goal here is uh
yeah to quantify and extrapolate the
capabilities of large language models um
and so we designed big bench as an open
call for tasks uh to the whole research
community and it was organized through
github um
and uh we evaluated the tasks on large
language models at google and open ai
evaluated them on their models
and now also other groups so big science
is evaluated on some of their models
deep mind evaluated some so the you know
the goal is to to collect these tasks
and then see how uh how their
performance improves as a function of
the model scales that they're evaluated
on um
and this is designed with zero shot and
few shot evaluations in mind and and
it's a living benchmark and actively
developed so if you're
think there's some great task and you
would love to see it evaluated on models
but don't you know
want to contribute it or don't want to
do the evaluations yourself like please
feel free to submit your task of
interest uh and you know we'll we'll
evaluate it for you
um
and so far this has resulted in over 200
tasks uh and and more than 400 um
contributors
um and okay you could say like right we
have a bunch of text benchmarks already
why do we need a new benchmark um and so
one reason is that you know models
models are getting quite good um and so
that often means that benchmarks are
saturated very quickly so here's a plot
from superglue um where we see that like
the human baseline was was
beat within a year of the benchmark
coming out
um
and but but despite that you know models
are still have glaring holes so here's
an example from big bench um you know if
we ask a model you know there's an empty
fruit basket then when fig is added then
one plum is added then when data's added
then when plumb is removed then when fig
is removed uh which fruits are in the
basket um it's happy to tell you that
this question would get 71 views um but
a related question about how quickly two
boys can finish work would actually get
over 1500 views so maybe you should have
been asking that instead
um you know which is not exactly the
answer we're looking for um
so um
you know we it's also the hope that you
know if we if we collect enough tasks
and if they're diverse and difficult
enough then
it'll take longer to saturate and also
we'll be able to slice these tasks along
different axes and maybe figure out you
know which which tasks are are
susceptible to scaling and which tests
are not
and also if we have a broad enough set
you know maybe that gives us a better
way of extrapolating when these
capabilities will will be or won't be
broadly human
yeah so this might be a little side
question but
the only uh case where i've seen that
this example here kind of gets quote
unquote solved is from like the
construct gpt work where they did some
reinforcement learning on human feedback
to kind of prevent like these uh this
kind of thing yeah yeah also fuchsia
prompting is quite effective at this
kind of thing too like you know here
it's like thinking
people i don't want to enter more fights
but
i think in some sense this is this has
the prompt has not been engineered that
much to get it out of the default
internet garbage mode into like yeah
because i've noticed that if you just
train a really large language model and
start asking questions like this you
just get some like kind of garbage
compressions like this yes i'm curious
if there's so the two main techniques
are still kind of prompting and also
maybe like some kind of reinforcement
learning with human feedback or just
fine tuning is also okay um yeah just a
bit of qa fine tuning it all
you know that's enough to get it
right so okay so here are some examples
of the types of tasks that we have at
the moment um there's a crash blossom
task which asks models to identify parts
of speech for um you know uh difficult
or ambiguous words within sentences
there's a code line description task
which gives the model a
python code and asks it to
guess what
what the code will do
there's the emoji movie task which gives
the model a sequence of emojis um
encoding the plot of some movie and the
model is supposed to figure out what
movie they're describing
um
and uh there's a interactive 20
questions where pairs and models are are
playing 20 questions with themselves
with each other and and they they win if
they're able to correctly communicate
the the 20 question target
um
and these tasks can be submitted either
as like simple json files with lists of
questions and answers or is more
complicated programmatic tasks that
perhaps require many interactions with
the model before uh before scoring
and if we look at how models do
here is aggregate performance uh for a
bunch of google and open ai models um
both denton sparse decoder only models
uh and we see that you know all of these
models uh generally speaking are
improving with scale
this is over the the subset of the json
task that i mentioned
um
but we also um
collected uh
evaluations from human raters um and so
we can uh we can compare you know how
the models are doing to those human
baselines and uh at the moment they
still have a pretty significant way to
go to to compete with the best best
human raters
um and this score
you know some of these tasks have
different types of metrics you know some
are multiple choice some are exact
string match some are measuring blue
some are measuring rouge so for each
task uh submission authors give a low
score and a high score and we can use
that to normalize and combine
and so here um you know 100 is is should
be thought of as like perfect on all the
tasks and zero is like random chance or
bad
okay so like a natural question from
this is okay the you know this bulk
performance is sort of relatively
systematically improving um albeit maybe
quite slowly um can we predict
performance on particular tasks
and so we can go and look at individual
tasks um so for instance here's a uh
translation task um which asks the model
to translate between um english and then
either rare or constructed languages um
and this task you know seems to be uh
seems to be systematically improving
with scale
but then other tasks don't show this
kind of improvement so here is a cause
and effect task um where a model is
asked to determine uh you know what is a
cause and what is effect so for instance
did the child hurt their knee because
they started crying um or or is it more
likely that it was the other way around
uh and and on this task the model you
know doesn't really show any improvement
um but then you know sort of a main
confounder to trying to use these to
extrapolate capabilities is that there
are tasks like this which seem to show
no improvement for many orders of
magnitude and then all of a sudden have
some jump uh jump in in improvement so
this is the emoji uh emoji movie task um
and uh
and we see some critical scale it turns
on and here you know the model is not
given any choices and it just has to it
has to pull the name of the movie you
know out of out of its memory of reading
about movies on the internet
um
how does sorry how does the
which numbers the the parameters that
are showing us on the x-axis in this
clause so these there's no fine-tuning
whatsoever on the tasks this is all uh
few shot evaluations
and so the there's
there's like the all of these models are
trained on on roughly the the same
amount of data um and you know to the
degree that it has overlap with the
emoji movie task that's just because the
internet is talking about emojis and
talking about
that
what how does that amount of data
yeah um
yes uh yeah this one is happening around
or maybe i mean it's on this log scale
so it's you know like it may be uh you
know depending on where you want to
point it out
so like this one where it's just
continuing to improve right
yeah and this one where it's not
improving at all
i mean the training data is the same for
all of these plots
oh i'm sorry okay i didn't realize that
so these are just these are just the one
shot a few shots yes all of this
everything i'll talk about here there's
no fine tuning yeah so um
i can't read the exponents i'm sorry so
yeah this is this this here makes sense
we say so the x-axis here the the scales
go from about two million to about a
hundred billion parameters so that's the
right hand
thank you
yeah sorry sorry about that um are other
problems tuned for each of the models or
are these just some fixed problems that
were given by the practice so the task
just has individual questions for these
and we just randomly sample um uh so
here's the shot is labeled like none of
them one of them two of them are three
of them and evaluate on the ones that
were held out so for a g shotgun
um i think
uh
the like tasks that are very hard for
humans are generally very hard for these
models
um
there are there are
tasks that are easy for humans can also
be hard for these models and then there
can be
rare exceptions where the model
seems to be better than
non-expert humans um which the you know
the raiders
have some expertise but they're
definitely not experts in all of the
tasks so for instance um
some of the translation tasks it seemed
like the model was outperforming the
raiders at this but
these are from uh
there are these
linguistic olympiad problems and so the
model was quite competent at this i
think it doesn't compare to like human
uh like medalists of these olympiads but
it seems in this case this was like one
of one of the few exceptions where like
that was sort of not well correlated to
the human raiders that we have
okay so uh sort of muddying the waters
even even further
like these trends that i'm like hoping
hoping to see and sort of like pointing
out they can strongly depend on on
things which which seem like you know
details that you wouldn't like them to
depend on so for instance um you know on
this cause and effect task you can
rephrase the task um so that you
actually do see improvement with scale
and strong performance um
so you know if you just ask the model
which is more probable the sentence the
child started crying because the child
hurt their knee or the child hurt their
knee because the child started crying
then you see that that you know scale
does help uh with this phrasing of the
question
in the left block does the model see
both the answers before it has to
do anything it it it's so the way these
multiple choices are evaluated is it
assigns it looks at the probability of
these two
and um and then
uh asks which is which is more probable
so it's prompted with this question and
then answer this one if that gives that
full sequence and probability
it's ask you know question and then
answer this one it gives the that
sentence some probability and then um
and then whichever probability is higher
that's taken as the model's answer and
then that scored does that make sense
yeah
that explanation makes sense but i don't
understand why
uh
uh it makes sense given the input prompt
that the model is given beforehand
because it isn't um
wouldn't you expect it to somehow like
see both of these and have to like so
we've evaluated in two ways one where
you if you say like choices and then it
shows both in the prompt and then you do
this and where you don't
um and uh um
that can actually have a big effect and
and actually it can often be the case
that well it can be the case that it
does better without showing showing the
choices um
uh
which yeah i mean i think that's not
what you'd expect right you expect the
choices to uh to just help but you know
maybe you think it's getting distracted
by having experts in the prompt or
something like that
or being pushed out of distribution
right so right so okay so here just you
know just rephrasing this way can can
change the trend um
uh
um
also uh the degree of regularity across
tasks can depend on how on how we grade
them so here's an emoji movie task if we
do this exact string match where it has
to pull the name um out of the blue we
see this this discontinuity if we give
it uh multiple choice questions in this
case also without showing it the options
um it seems more more uh more systematic
um
and these things can also depend not
just on on how we phrase the question
but but how we score it so um you know
if we're looking at multiple choice
grades sometimes we see these jumps if
we're looking at what's the probability
that the model of science is the correct
answer that can often look smooth
um
and there's also phenomena where it
seems like the model might not be
learning much you might be learning
really slowly
so here this this is um this is these
are mostly like multiple choice
accuracies so does it um
does it
select the correct the correct you know
it's comparing now a probability of
correct answer to probabilities of wrong
answers
and so to get it right it has to have
that the right answer probability has to
be higher than the wrong answers whereas
here it's just what's the probability of
the right answer so like a cross-entropy
type loss for this
um and that that's smooth so it's just
continuing to assign better and better
probability to the right answer but it
only that only beats the wrong answers
here
so uh similar to like the grocking paper
it had like this this logarithmic x-axis
and i saw one criticism of it is like
you just make it a linear x-axis it
actually looks quite smooth because like
the difference between 10 to the 10.
yeah uh do you have any
uh just comment on like uh the
appropriateness of using the logarithmic
x-axis for setting these like and
calling them discontinuities yeah uh did
i say that um i think
like if i wanted to be diplomatic i
think definitely jury is still out about
discontinuity um i mean some of these
look quite dramatic even on uh you know
even on a linear axis but this yeah can
skew things but i think like
experiments like this are sort of first
attempts of trying to understand is
there actually some fundamental
discontent going on or something smooth
um
yeah so um
yeah i mean i think it's good to plot it
in both ways and i think like for me
um
i think like whether there's a like a
real phase transition that's underlying
this it you know uh i haven't talked
about some like models you know
speculative models after but is the
jury's still out um
just just briefly
uh and maybe related to attempts to
understand that you can ask like even
for tasks which seem like they're not
showing much improvement so here's a
task where the model is asked to find
check it's given a series of moves
leading the chess board to some state
and then
there should be one checkmating move
after it and the model's asked you know
given that the the whole game in context
can it find the checkmate so that's the
task
um
and you can look you know how is the
model doing at finding checkmates uh and
that's this red line here it's not doing
great um it's worse than if it um uh
yeah it's it then you can ask well
actually sometimes it finds checkmates
it just doesn't use chest notation it
forgets to put the the uh
the pound sign before it's checkmate so
hope this pink line is if you just find
it like like let's just be happy to
found checkmate um so still not not a
huge improvement but you can just ask
okay what kind of moves is it making and
it's actually making more and more legal
moves so
um to some degree you know maybe the
model isn't learning checkmates at a
rate that we're happy with but it
actually is getting pretty good at
making legal check chess moves in this
setting
when you evaluate these moments are you
evaluating the 12 council or are you
evaluating your country what exactly
um this is
uh
so um
it's the the top answer yeah but yeah do
you think that's
right like do you think that's what we
should be doing then maybe you should
leave your majority
yeah i'll talk about other inference
techniques in a bit but i i think i
think like i think these are all good
ideas and like we can like yeah put like
maybe put this into what we call the
model but then think about yeah how do
we change things to improve on this
yeah definitely there are smarter things
you can do than this
okay so um
right so uh
so yeah so in conclusion you know big
benches large benchmark um one thing
that i found nice about it was like i'm
maybe interested in some topic not
thinking about big bench and then i'll
realize oh actually there's like a
related task already in big bench if i
want to know how it scales i can just
like pull up the plot that's already
been computed and see like does that
task get better with scale or not so
like perhaps if you're interested in
something maybe there's a related task
already there that like you can get you
know used to build some intuition um
if there's not a task there and you'd
like to know yeah please please
um
please submit and i think yeah
understanding this breakthrough behavior
is very important for for our ability to
like extrapolate capabilities um and
also i think is like a rich a rich
target for a theoretical analysis um
and also you know we see here lots of
tasks which are systematically improving
but at a rate which is totally
infeasible to think about using this as
the approach to solving so you know just
something you know getting better with
scale doesn't necessarily mean that
scale is like the answer to solving this
problem
um
okay great so
um now i wanted to move on to a couple
of focus problems um and the first one i
wanted to talk about you know the the
role scale plays in catastrophic
forgetting
yeah how can scaling language modules
help with limiting hallucination
limiting who's nation
um uh yeah that i mean that's a good
question i don't actually don't know off
the top of my head of
yeah results on that but yeah i think
that's yeah okay great question
i think there was one paper that came
with us
um
well yeah so okay so um what's the
typical catastrophic forgetting setup um
the typical setup is that we
sequentially train on two tasks so for
instance say we want first to classify
muffins versus chihuahuas
we train a model to do that and then we
subsequently train on classifying
chickens uh chicken fried chicken versus
poodles um and once we're training on
the chicken versus poodle task the
chihuahua versus muffin task performance
we typically drop so that's the usual
uh forgetting setup
uh and you know maybe it's interesting
on its own right i think the real reason
we care about this is we think it's a
good probe of a more general phenomena
which is just that uh if uh just if we
have distribution shift during training
uh then often that can interfere with
models performance
on previous tasks
and why might we think that
scale might be helpful for this so one
one
piece of intuition comes from
thinking about language models again
which is that you know here's an example
of another task for big bench which is
just asking a model um to match the
atomic number to um
to an element so this is like a recall
task in uh large models are quite good
at this but presumably whatever data
used to learn that this data set of
training is huge so presumably that was
many gradient steps back you know in
training between when that appeared and
when this model was evaluated on it um
and yet it's still able to do right very
well at this in this view shot setting
so so this you know um leads one to
believe that like you know it can retain
information you know these big models
can retain information for many grading
updates
um and so sort of in that spirit uh
we
we uh decided to pre-train some big
models on imagenet 21k um and then study
like how how forgetting was dependent on
on the scale of blue training data and
model size
and the way i'll mostly be plotting
things just to orient people is on this
2d task a versus task b
um plot and i'll sometimes refer to the
forgetting frontier and you know the
point is if we think about we've trained
on task a and now we're training on task
b we start out with some good task a
performance and then as we train longer
on task b
our task b performance gets better and
our task a performance gets worse and so
like models that forget less are models
that are moved further up into the right
on this on this plot
um
great and so yeah so we can look at like
you know how do these big pre-trained
models do
on on forgetting tasks um and so here
are some uh vision transformers and
resnets and we see that we get uh you
know quite dramatic improvements um
in in forgetting so this is just taking
the best average accuracy um that we can
get so choosing the optimal stopping
time in that way um for these models and
and we get these um we get this uh you
know improvement with scale
oh okay but this you know this raises
some questions you might say like oh
well is it just about model size so one
way to get at that is um instead of
doing this pre-training we can just we
can just train models from scratch on on
the first subset and then ask you know
how do they do on on uh you know when we
do task speed training and we see that
really to take advantage of this scaling
it's not just not enough to just have
you know bigger models we also have to
have to have scaled up our pre-training
data set size
you could say like okay fine but like
pre-training and bigger models that like
improves accuracy maybe it's just about
accuracy um that we get you know maybe
if your test accuracy is just good
enough then you don't you don't forget
that much so here is some experiments
where um uh we we uh handicapped the
task a training of the pre-trained
models so that its performance matches
what we get from a train from scratch
model on this task a task um and we
still see that pre-training and scale
confer infer benefits even when we're
matching original task accuracy
um
uh
you know another question which i think
i think the you know i think actually
understanding this deeply is
is uh interesting question um is that
like to what degree does the overlap
between
the tasks you're doing your forgetting
study in and this pre-training data that
you trained on what what what's the
importance of the overlap between those
i think like you know my name you've
guessed was that like you know if you
have a big diverse pre-training data set
and your next tasks are like sort of
within it that's sort of like a good
recipe for
mitigating forgetting and like you know
that that's great like it still presents
an approach and you could maybe have a
big unsupervised pre-training data set
size and then have supervised tasks um
but it turned out that actually this
behavior um you know maybe
requires us to rethink what we mean by
in and out of distribution or extended
further out of distribution than i
expected so here's some experiments on a
variety of uh fine-tuning tasks and in
particular
uh you know we saw
pretty good behavior on um svhn
forgetting and and domainnet art
forgetting and you know image that has
no numbers in it and and it has no
clipart in it and so you know the you
know
maybe that's fine and we shouldn't think
of those as being out of distribution
but at least like some naive guess of
what where i might expect to see this
breakdown didn't didn't happen
okay so yeah how much data were in the
task and has to be
how big are those tasks yeah so that's
that that was so for each of those it's
like whichever task is there it's split
so like for the cfar 10 it's like five
classes and then five classes
do you think like the scaling is
possibly just like deferring the problem
like if you scale the task up while you
scale the model it's i think that's
quite likely that if you make it big
enough that like
um
that
like sorry uh
so okay sorry let me say this in a way
that i actually believe so i think like
i think if you just kept like these c
splits and just took more id samples
from that i don't expect there to be a
significant problem
um
uh but if you if you like started adding
more and more tasks that had to keep and
it was supposed to keep remembering all
of them
my so we did this for 10 different
splits but still like like my guess is
that there's some amount of continual
learning that like will compete like
there's some way in which you need to
scale the amount of continual learning
with your amount of like pre-training
and model scale to uh to take advantage
of this so like at some point like
you're you know if you have enough data
you'll you'll sort of
yeah wipe out they'll like you know be
enough to saturate the capacity of your
model and then you won't get this kind
of
uh improvement it's my guess i think it
would be interesting to understand like
how those two scale together
so you're saying that for the bigger
model if you fix the same two tasks and
you scale up those two tasks it should
be fine but if you increase the number
of tests itself then it might start to
yeah i suspect that's yeah yeah
any insights from linear models for
catastrophic
um yeah there are some actually um
um
so
one one feature of like these these uh
forgetting is that it often happens in
the last layer of the network um
and and uh so if that's true you can you
can model this quite well because now
you have some pre-trained features and
you're training a linear model on top of
those pre-trained features
um you know because if it was true that
was literally in the last layer of your
network then you would just have some
frozen features
multiplied by some linear weights
and so one one thing you can learn there
is like
you might ask um if i'm training on task
a and task b how does the similarity
between those two tasks affect the
amount of forgetting and what you find
is if the tasks are
uh very similar like you know id data
from the same task of course you have no
forgetting if the tasks are very
different you also have very little
forgetting so if those linear features
are like orthogonal then you you they
don't interfere and you have very little
forget it and that it's actually this
intermediate similarity that leads to
maximal forgetting and you can you can
like drive this behavior in this frozen
feature linear models setting and so
that's also another motivation for
scaling up is you know maybe with no
training i can't recognize that like
this subset of c4 and this subset of
cpar are actually like pretty orthogonal
but if i had a huge model that's
pre-trained now like even without these
labels it's great at having features
that represent cats and dogs differently
than planes and trucks like those have
very little overlap and so if low
overlap is a recipe for getting low
forgetting that's sort of part of the
motivation of why another motivation of
why you might think like large scale
pre-trading is helpful for getting low
forgetting
what's a good metric for uh measuring
how similar to tasks are yeah that's
again that's i think a
good question in general here in that
frozen model you can look at the overlap
between these features so so in this
model where it is just the last layer
like you can use that as a proxy even in
the case where you're training the whole
thing and that seems to correlate quite
well in this case
um okay so
in in just a couple of remaining minutes
um i wanted to to move on to this
question of like um you know
quantitative reasoning something
something that you know a pool chef
we're quite interested in is like you
know how can we get models yeah to be
better scientists how can can we have
them do quantitative reasoning um
and so then we you know a natural
question we like to ask is like okay
what degree is scale helpful in this um
and so you know in general we want like
general purpose you know quantitative
reasoners i'll often be focusing sort of
on a toy window into that which is you
know uh science and math question
answering type problems
and you know many have speculated that
like we need like you know scale is not
going to be that helpful with this you
know maybe we need symbolic logic or you
know something else that we're missing
for for these kind of you know maybe
quantitative reasoning is different than
language model
um and so to try to try to investigate
this directly um uh we trained um
a a big model on uh you know
unsupervised but math heavy data set um
and um
and uh just trying to see you know what
we could get in terms of in terms of
quantitative reasoning skills
um and so you know the ingredients are
you know yeah math heavy data set a
large pre-trained model pre-trained on
general text and then further
unsupervised fine-tuning or additional
pre-training if you want to call that on
on a data set that contains a lot of
math um and then some input sign
techniques which i'll walk through in a
second
uh right so um
the key to the data set was just making
sure that it wasn't over clean so some
naive cleaners will destroy mathematical
notation like you have a over b and that
just becomes a space b or in this
example you you have you know e equals m
c squared and the cleaner just changes
it to emc2 and so it's hard to imagine
that if you're ruining the like logic in
the data the model will learn any logic
um and so yeah we took palm which is an
existing internal big pre-trained model
and then further trained it on this
you know not over cleaned uh
scrape of archive and and web pages that
had math jacks on them yep
and the
unsupervised client journey is you know
predicting next token yeah yeah same
yeah so
um okay and then we evaluated it and to
evaluate it we used a few uh techniques
which which have become popular so one
is it's called chain of thought or
scratch pad and so you know the typical
flu shot you prompt with question answer
question answer question here instead
you prompt with question justification
answer question justification answer
question and that encourages the model
as it's answering the question to spit
out some justification which hopefully
it can use that justification to like
you know reason about uh its answer
before spitting out the answer and also
it lets us like investigate you know a
perhaps flawed window into how the
model's coming to an answer
um and then we also did majority voting
which means we don't just take one
most likely answer the model generates a
bunch of answers so here it generates a
bunch of reasoning steps and a bunch of
final answers so you know maybe it'll
come to you know the answer five three
times and the answer two one time you
know those fives will have different
ways it got there but there's more five
so before grading it we let it take the
majority vote over these samples and
that's that's what's used as the final
answer
um
okay and so you know with that
you get quite um
you know quite big improvement on on
performance on a lot of um you know math
and science data sets so there's this um
hendrix math data set um
which is asking um uh high school high
school level but like contest problems
across a variety of
math domains there's mmlu stem which is
asking questions over a variety of stem
subjects we also evaluated on various
high school undergraduate and graduate
course questions um
and you know the model the model does
learn at least
or at least is able to imitate in some
examples you know reasoning quite well
and quite better than
previous models were able to
um
and i think so uh i know i should rap
but just uh it's you know i don't know i
find it fun to inspect
oh i have 50 more minutes oh all right
great um so i can talk like in a page
that people can actually understand um
yeah so anyways it's fun to
or well i find it fun to like you know
inspect and anthropomorphize um
you know this this model of solving
certain problems so like here's an
example
where
it's um you know asked to figure out uh
the velocity sorry the speed for a model
uh for a particle moving on a circle um
and you know it's able to um take the
derivative and then compute the
magnitude of the vector and then spit
out spit out the answer
um
one
one fun thing is um
you know so this model is trained in
this unsupervised fashion on like all
the data we could scrape that had tech
in it and so a lot of that data the tech
is importing some drawing package and
then drawing something and making some
statement about the thing that it drew
and so that means you know out of the
box the model is able to do some
reasoning about uh questions with
diagrams so like here i'm drawing it in
a way which i find easier to see where
it actually has the diagram of course
what the model is seeing is just the um
tech package that draws the diagram so
this one's asymptote which i didn't know
until
seeing the model spit out asymptote a
bunch but i guess it's a popular drawing
package you can also do this for like
tic-zee or other things like that um and
what i like about this example um is so
so it's asked to compute the area of
these gray regions um and the way i
would have solved it is i would have
like computed the rectangle and then
subtracted the the pink uh triangle um
and this this um
the questions in math come with a
reference answer which which the model
um hasn't seen but that's also how the
reference answer does it the way the
model decided to do it was that it
recognized that these were both
triangles themselves um and so it
separately computed the area of those
two triangles and then added them
together um you know anyways which you
know is totally fine and maybe that's i
don't know
what other people's like default would
be but
you know it tickled the model is doing
it differently than what i thought would
be like easiest you know the night
could be because that's how it's it's
coated up like there's like two positive
triangles is there one negative triangle
good question yeah that that's um worth
looking at i like another anecdote along
those lines is sometimes i was like oh
this model solving this problem is like
it just like
is doing it like instantly like it's
asked to get the area of a region and
it's just like well the length is this
and the width is this so the area is
that like why you know you're supposed
to reason about like so okay the
concrete example is you have a rectangle
divided up into four sub rectangles
you're given the area of three and
you're asked for the area of the fourth
okay and the model was just saying oh
it's the the fourth area like the the
length is this the width is this the
area is that and it's like well how did
you know that you must have memorized
the training data at this point like you
know very nervous about memorization and
stuff so okay then you look at the code
and they've like hard hard-coded in the
size of each of these things you know so
you don't see this when you're when
you're uh but so okay so um
yeah so and you know and if you change
the numbers the model is able to change
with so you know i think it is just
cheating by looking at the code not
cheating by memorizing the uh the
internet
yeah the the model also definitely has
its fair share of failure modes um so
some examples are false positives those
those are sort of
you know the most difficult because it
makes you question the score you're
getting and it also if you want to use
it samples to like do further training
or something like that it would be nice
if you could lead out false positives so
here's an example where the question
asks um
asks you to
to um
continue this pattern and and ask if you
continue to what with the 30th number be
and the way the model approaches it is
it thinks the pattern continues by just
having all the remaining lines have five
numbers in them so like five sixes five
sevens five eighths but in this case
that's a that like gives you the same
thing as doing it correctly and so you
know the model clearly has the wrong
logic here but but the problem isn't
sharp enough to
distinguish that
um
you know there are other examples many
examples that it just gets wrong you
know here's a cherry-picked one where
it's asked to solve this equation um and
it decides that we can just cancel the
square root um and then it uses that to
try to solve the try to solve the
equation
which would be great but unfortunately
um
okay so um
uh
right so um yeah i wanted to conclude
and then maybe have time for questions
also we can i have more examples if
people are curious to see but um
uh
so you know
right so so so definitely
it's not at all clear that scale is
enough to solve you know most or all of
the questions we care about but i
definitely think you know it continues
to be a option that is worth trying even
you know like it sort of
at least for me like is
you know
often surprising what you can get from
scaling things up without
much clever you know many clever ideas
and i think it's a useful no model to to
you know rate other things against
um
uh
you know i think from a theory
perspective some some things follow like
very robust predictable trends and so
that's just sort of you know sometimes
independent of details of architecture
sometimes independent details of data
and that's the kind of thing that just
begs your theoretical understanding um
and then
there's also this counterpoint that
there are other things we definitely
don't understand when trying to predict
performance on particular tasks and if
we if there's a goal of trying to
extrapolate predict performance or or
understand what's going there i think
that's also a very important target um
and then sort of going back to this
normal perspective
you know
if we're thinking about things like
hallucinations or you know um
architectural modifications
it's often useful at least for me yeah
to say like well okay how like how
like how how do i compare to doing
nothing like you know if i if i change
some detail of my architecture and i you
know get some maybe better performance
at some scale like does it change the
scaling exponent does it change the
prefactor like maybe
maybe you're still excited if it doesn't
or you know or maybe you're you know
pre-factors can be very important but at
least as a method for organizing how to
think about different types of research
i think it's quite uh useful like so
um
yeah uh with that i guess i'll close and
just say thanks thanks for letting me
speak
so we have about five minutes for the
many questions
and choosing a majority i guess of the
of the answer so so the um the way that
this like the
grading work so for the performance
plots yeah we would we would generate
256 examples and then we would say each
of each example has its own reasoning
and then its own final answer so we
would aggregate over the final answer
and we would ask how many
um how many had that would use that in
the cherry pick samples you just picked
like the first or random one from the
256 to show right okay and uh
so i guess i guess the randomness that's
there is the randomness that's used to
generate these these things that's right
it's some temperature we use temperature
0.8 i think for this
and i'm curious what's the
for those sorts of examples what's the
variation that you see between them is
it variation reasoning or is it yeah um
this uh
that's a great question um there's
there's there's some reasoning variation
there's also like just phrase like style
variations
for the east like so these problems in
addition to having categories they're
also graded like in the math problems
for instance which are the ones spent
the most time inspecting um they're also
graded by level so they'll be like
algebra 1 algebra 2 algebra 3 not just
algebra so for the for the simpler
problems we often found much less
variation in the way the model was
answering it and like if the answer is
short also a lot less variation um
and then as the problems got harder you
would you would typically see you know a
bit more variety and how
the model answered i think
these kind of questions are interesting
and also i think like you know a
standard thing that is always very
useful and often like more useful than
being clever is also ensembling models
and so like definitely
thinking about like can we can we
promote even more diversity and how it's
answering these and stuff like that
uh yeah so i'm trying to consolidate
what you were mentioning here about
minerva with uh another recent paper of
yours which is on length generalization
and i'm curious how you like
uh think about the two in conjunction
where you have the the length generates
generalization results so like horrible
uh model performance yeah out of
distribution stuff and then so does that
kind of imply that like minerva's
abilities to do what it's doing
are kind of suggesting that somehow the
number of like decision steps required
for these
or like in distribution compared to
being trained that's right yeah yeah i
think like
again with like harder tasks like
you know one of the ways it can fail is
like maybe reasoning through an answer
requires like 20 steps not like three
steps and then it like you know can have
a mistake at some intermediate point um
yeah i think you know even even there
there you know there are techniques to
try like to try to you can take a
problem
yep with some of this prompting you know
sometimes the problem can stay the same
but by cleverly prompting you sort of
can make it a distribution problem
rather than out of distribution problem
so for instance
long addition is a thing which people
say oh these models are very bad
generalization of long addition and
that's definitely true and like lots of
ways you prompt them they are bad at it
and but it turns out there are some ways
of like engineering a prompt or asking
it differently where these kind of
questions are more in distribution and
then so i mean that's i think you like
that's not a
solution like you'd really like some
robust procedure that let you
generalize beyond that and not just sort
of like happily try things and see what
works um so hey short answer is yes i
think basically
it's not inconsistent and it's just that
there's enough like you know
zero to ten step uh type things in the
training data that that's you know can
be emulated here i think understanding
like how that fails would be good but
yeah
like to get like long-form reasoning
probably requires more than
just just
maybe one more question
yeah
so you started the talk of talking about
kernels and you went on to transformers
which feels super different
is your intuition for like why you sort
of like the reason why you're able to
construct power loss failing for kernels
like is there anything that you see
carrying over to the transformer setting
or is it just facebook
yeah that's a great question um and like
i'll give an answer which i think is
like maybe very optimistic and could
like easily be criticized by like
someone who wants me to be formal um
like there's another approach
to getting these kind of scaling laws um
where you don't assume some particular
model structure at all um you just uh
you you
the key assumption is like smooth
functions on uh smooth ish and probably
that can be weakened too data manifold
um and then there are results um they're
like classic results in the literature
that you know if
i'm you know sometimes they're phrased
as
uh mesh interpolation results so like if
i'm trying to approximate this manifold
with a mesh with some number of vertices
how does my error scale with the number
of vertices sometimes the phrases
nearest neighbor you know it's really a
nearest neighbor question because as i
scale up my number of vertices or as i
scale my training data set size the
distance to my nearest neighbors scales
like uh a power law but that power is
controlled by one over the dimension of
the manifold you know nearest neighbors
are further if the dimension is is
bigger but as i add more data then your
snipers get closer so uh
that kind of
perspective also is what's underlying
the linear story if you believe this
like smooths kernel like the smoothness
on a d-dimensional data manifold is
what's driving it and but that can be
generalized it doesn't it just needs
smoothness it doesn't need some
particular architecture assumption
i don't know that that's literally
what's happening but that at least seems
like a root to some general story that
connects these things
for what smoothness in language like
respect natural language
um so the way i yeah i think that's a
great question the way i usually think
about this is in
embedding space for all this stuff so
when i'm talking about like nearest
neighbors i'm talking about like the
model's representation of data and so
there
it is more like there it is like
smoothness like actual smoothness on on
the representation
[Music]
[Applause]
and we now have about a half an hour
break we'll be back for the next
tutorial at 11 15.